jack and i met on a magical night out
um when i humiliated myself more than
i've ever had before
it was probably the best moment of my
life
it was the worst subject
for the first time ever like in my
career i never assume anyone knows who i
am
and i saw
harrison ford and like jj abrams
and i was like i was like yeah this is
fine we're all
co-workers like i can just go so i was
like
be right back guys i'm gonna go say hi
to the star wars dudes and i approached
their table and was like
and they all the whole table was just
like
and so i realized while i was dancing i
was like they have no idea who i am
and so i just turned around and walked
back
dying i've done this show with harrison
ford so he's like the only a-list
hollywood star that i know i mean he's
the only one that i had
so she had just been blanked and i was
like hey it's all right i'll go say hi
to harrison
everyone in the group was like jack
don't do this you will be humiliated i
was like nah me and harrison are tight
they genuinely had no idea so i get up i
walk over and at this point i'm like oh
god maybe he won't remember me
i will be humiliated as well i walked
over and literally as i walked over he
was like hey jack
sometimes i have to introduce the guests
but uh sercia and timothy now you know
each other yeah we're best friends yes
well you might are you i don't know
we're as close as we could be
okay no you met on the ladybird
do you know each other before that uh
yeah we met we met on ladybird and we've
kind of just been together ever since
because we ended up doing press together
after that and what's the story with you
calling timothy pony that's not a thing
is it yeah you said it was a thing
no what happened was we were doing an
interview when timmy was doing stuff for
comedy by your name and i was doing
stuff for lady bird and we did an
interview and i i said in the interview
that timmy is timmy is like a he's like
a horse he'll just come up to you and
he'll just sort of
nuzzle you just randomly
and and i think of him as a as a
boy horse
yeah exactly see
if you weren't always meryl streep what
oh
no at birth at birth
i had to be named mary because my
mother's name was mary and her mother's
name was mary and her mother marian
i named my first daughter mary
because i'm you know yeah
i'm that way what is that what is that
way what do you call it creature of
habit no trying to fit in all right you
know and make everybody happy in the
family basically
so um
yeah but my mother's
what was the question i'm dead
you weren't married my name you weren't
married
[Applause]
i was born mary and louise was my
mother's best friend louise buckman so i
was named after her
and um but i was always called meryl my
father's made that name up and he he
liked that name and so i hated it
i wanted to be named
patty or kathy or
that's how they said it in my town patty
cathy debbie
you'd be such a different person if you
would be brought up wouldn't you i don't
know yeah probably yes
but i had glasses and my name was
merrell
it had a pea on the end the street
should have been street i always wish
why didn't they just put the t on the
end instead of
p
you know what i remember yeah yeah it's
all coming out now
tyler perry you're a very tall handsome
man but if i was writing a film right
and i was writing a scene that i was
going to be in and i was going to be on
a beach with the other people is it i
would not have hired uh is it michael j
white michael j white sure yeah uh i i
just ought to be like no you can't be in
my film
he has a horrible looking swelling is he
okay
no he's ridiculously buff yeah but
that's why you hire him because the
people who are going to see the movie
there you want them to want to see him
because i
if i take the shirt off man i'm telling
you i i look like that
but that's why i didn't take the shirt
off
because i didn't want to show him up no
of course harder would be too much it's
his moment yes yes it's my film so i'll
give him his moment that's beautiful
have we kept launch at sea in your
bottom or not
no i think i probably i mean you can't
be an actress and not see a bottle
because i read you had a stunt bottom
a stunt bottom on elizabeth was that
well i did ask for an upgrade i said
look if you want to see my bottom let's
get a better one and did you meet the
lady the bottom yes i don't know whether
it was my bottom or her bottom in the
end i didn't really look that closely
but you don't see your own bottom very
often too so how would i know but we did
you like it well i didn't really i mean
i don't do
if have you i'd look at you
i would look at your bottom if it was on
screen would you do you know what while
you're looking at her bottom i'd look at
your body
this was about 10 years ago
i did a film with morgan freeman it was
a really small film and the first 10
pages or 10 minutes of the film are us
two just driving together in a car
and talking and it took three days to
shoot and uh he didn't talk to me the
entire time like in between takes right
because he had so much dialogue i
learned later right okay so he was just
you know so in between we wouldn't
really chat and but we were in the car
together for three days and then at the
end of the third day
he just turns to me and he goes jonah
jonah babona banana fana fufona me ma
momona
[Laughter]
it was one of the more weird moments of
my life
and i just didn't know what to say so i
just said thank you
and then he said it was quiet again and
he said
do me
what he's like
do my name
and i was like do your name and he's
like yeah do my name and i was like
morgan morgan boborgan
me my mo morgan
morgan
he went all right and then we never
spoke again
at first i'm low to himesh patel now a
lot of people they leave soaps like
eastenders and they they're going to
pursue a film career uh
you've done it my god you're you're the
star of a big movie well done you thank
you
because you must you know because you
were in you were on the square for how
many years uh close to nine years yeah
so you must have waved goodbye to a lot
of people thinking good luck yeah yeah
and i bet they're all thinking we'll see
him again in about a year
yeah it's gone well i don't know there
you are as tamworth on the thing
uh you you'd lots of realize you were a
market inspector you were the maitre d
of the rj bhaji
um
great night but now how did this happen
uh yes
because that was part of the show yeah i
wish you'd won that tonight
but i thought against
but uh this was about a year after i
joined the show
and they'd kind of got the measure of me
they realized that i liked comedy and i
liked kind of having a laugh but their
idea of
using that was to do the storyline where
tanwa starts doing
impressions of other people in the
square and putting them online
and
and i had to do this this like half a
day where i was just sat in front of
what looks like tarpaulin or it felt
like i was being held hostage
and i had to do that one of of dot
cotton and uh they had these herbal
cigarettes
and that i was like
like trying to smoke i was like i don't
i don't want to do this please don't
make me do that
it did feel like a hostage situation
june brown found it funny i don't know
if june ever saw it
because i got to i i had a love lovely
time with jun pam saying clement i did
uh pat butcher oh yeah um i feel like
she must have seen it because i've i
never spoke to her
nine years we never had a conversation i
didn't think really yeah wow she holds a
grudge old pam yeah
it was about 15 years ago when the six
cents came out bruce willis won the
people's choice award for best actor
and he asked me to present the award to
him so i did and i went backstage that
night and i met haley joel osman from
the movie and i met m night shyamalan
and about six months later i was at this
bar this is back when i was drinking and
i was with a couple of friends and m
night shyamalan walked in and he said hi
matthew and i went oh my god hi how are
you please sit down join us and he sat
down and he joined us and we sat there
for about an hour talking and i noticed
my friends sort of filtered out and then
it was just me and m night shyamalan for
about another hour and i noticed we
weren't talking about show business or
anything we were just kind of talking
about women and love and loss and life
and all that and
he mentioned that there was another club
opening across town and would i like to
go with him
and i said sure i'd love to go with you
and
i had this weird moment which i never
had i've had before where i was
convinced that i was going to be a big
movie star as a result of this night
because he was laughing at all my jokes
he really was sort of into me i think he
might have been a big friends fan
he was really liking me yeah and so we
get to the next place and i felt
comfortable enough sort of drunk enough
to say we should work together sometime
and he kind of went like this
and i remember going oh i wish i hadn't
said that
and then he went to the bathroom and a
friend of mine came up to me and said
how's your night going and i said what
are you kidding i'm having the greatest
night of my life eminem shyamalan and i
have been hanging out for the last two
and a half hours it's been great
and the guy might shyamalan came back
from the bathroom and my friend said
that's not my night shyamalan
it wasn't
it was just an indian gentleman
who looked a lot
[Laughter]
and i had said to him let's work
together
and it turned out he was a maitre d at a
local restaurant
have you ever seen him again since no
but i've seen the guy and we always look
at each other like jilted lovers
[Applause]
[Music]
you